I don't know what to do about this
Benji's who dressed up weird like almost
in a Halloween costume did you see him I
haven't seen long hair now there's a wig
on with a long hair oh dear buddy what's
going on just tell me what's happening
is this from this is for my benefit
obviously right you're wearing a wig and
well I getting weird and that beard is
weird and everything is weird I know
it's shocking to you because you all
right do I look that weird yeah you look
it's I don't know what you're doing and
what are you wearing a wig to pay I
don't know she says integrated hair it's
not mine let me say it's it's not but
but it looks good doesn't I mean it
looks like hair can you take it off or
is it like glued on
it's know it's like it's sewn in yeah I
honestly think it looks great is this
weird look when he looks at himself he
opens up his eyes wide like that like a
heaven like a supermodel for photoshoot
yeah
but I do look good don't I I think he
looked fine the other way all right
what's going on what are you doing are
you doing this for my but I guess he is
doing it for my benefit so I'll talk to
him on the air exactly you know what it
is it's like this huge distraction how
do you not address that right somebody
walked in looking completely different
than they've ever looked before he's
wearing a Halloween costume so how do I
ignore that I'm almost at the point
where I just want to throw him out of
the room he doesn't have to be in the
studio to perform his job it's annoying
it's it's I can't take my eyes off this
[ __ ] train wreck and I know you're
doing it so I could get talked about on
the air and it's I feel manipulated by
you he had an idea what he was gonna do
this morning and yeah
I can't I had notes on what I want to
talk about and now I'm saying you're
staring at Benjy I just feel manipulated
I really can't hide you like I see you
out of the corner of my eye and it's a
big wad of hair is honestly I've always
wanted to have hair and this was a way
of trying no you don't we have a
vacation coming up do it then and with
then you'll be burned out on it in two
weeks
I understand it's startling but I swear
it's not like I want to look good it's
not why are you wearing eye makeup what
is that about like big black eye makeup
if you had a guitar and you were on
stage I guess it even if you were I
wouldn't go to your [ __ ] concert I
really wouldn't heard of Ozzy Osbourne
that's blobby Osborne blotchy blotchy ah
so [ __ ] odd but I know you want to
project that no I'm caught up in it no
I'm not no I'm caught up in it what do
you mean no I'm not
I am projected yeah why would you come
to work like that Benjy I said to my ABC
what can I go you know we're working
[Music]
just saw me didn't know me didn't look I
don't I know you do that I know you you
look weird if I just saw you and I
didn't know you how could I know you I
know but if you didn't do you think it
would look that weird yeah yeah I think
he looks strange you don't think it look
like like you would stand up and what
and stand over by the microphone so
Robyn and I could look I gotta be done
with this yeah yeah I know it's just
it's just a spicoluk I'm starting to
sweat a little sweat going on he's got
the fake hair on you know obviously a
woman who gets a facelift he's trying to
keep his face straight right he's what
that look as he sees in the mirror just
like by moving his face I think I look
like calling for you I mean there's even
sparkles on his face cheese that's
partners that's wet no it sparkles wet
spark
you look like Zoolander when Ben Stiller
starts posing like a model that's what
you look like
wasn't he supposed to be good-looking in
that movie dude stop it all right and
then oh god I forgot that nail polish so
he can look attractive to his girlfriend
and I do and then she can't touch you
because she'll knock the glitter off
your hair will come off there's no way
she's attracted to him I know he's
definitely attracted yeah okay all right
I'm telling you she's not I don't care
what you two make out is that what
you're saying yeah I went and I mean you
have to get into all this to get a kiss
as long as the tanning stuff is dry and
dude it looks it looks I'm being
honestly it looks ridiculous I know you
want hair but it doesn't look like real
hair all right looking in the stem cells
off to look into them Sal yeah okay
thanks you're getting a new human being